bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got will
back here with me
uh thanks for jumping on real quick and
uh let's just start off with
the price of bitcoin went down
maybe not a lot but it went down over
the last couple of days and into the
weekend
uh before it came roaring back what
drove the sell-off in price
yeah sure so there's been a lot of
speculation on twitter about
what the catalyst was um but i think you
know
it really comes down to the fact that
there was a lot of leverage um
futures open interest was like off the
charts and so basically means there's a
lot of
there's a lot of greed in the bitcoin
markets everyone was super over
leveraged
every time price went up you know
everybody hopped in on their 10x long
100x long on bitmex and
wanted to you know ride this thing as
they thought it was going to explode
and so what happens is when there's that
much leverage in the system it makes
it makes it very fragile right and you
can kind of analogize it to like
if you think about jenga where you're
stacking the jangle blocks higher and
higher it just the higher you go
the less of a push it takes to push the
price back down
and so there's been a lot of speculation
i know willie wu had talked about um
the hash rate had something to do with
it the power outage in china um and then
speculators had kind of
um freaked out and tried to you know
sell off to
um avoid a further sell-off which kind
of became like a self-uh
fulfilling thing right so that could be
true
um just by looking at the data we did
see a giant inflow of about 9 000
bitcoins onto binance
and binances is primarily used in asia
which would kind of line up with that
theory
that somebody had some kind of insider
information about what was going on with
the power outage and they were trying to
avoid
um you know the sell-off that they
figured would come but it really comes
down to the fact regardless of what the
catalyst is
it comes down to the fact that there was
a lot of leverage and so
um when you have the market that highly
leveraged it's very prone to these kind
of events right
and so throughout the last week we've
seen that leverage just get completely
flushed out
um when you look at when you look at the
funding rates
which is how you know on these trading
platforms in bitcoin we have something
called the perpetual swap
so it's basically this contract this
futures contract that doesn't expire
that's pegged to the bitcoin price and
the way it's pegged to the price is
through funding rates right so
when when the majority of the market
goes short uh the funding rates go
negative right and then it becomes
profitable to take the other side of the
trade to go long
same the other way around right when
when everybody wants to go long
funding rates go up you and the the
people that are long are actually paying
people to go
short to keep the price on the perpetual
swap peg to
the market uh spot price right and so
for
for weeks now we had incredibly high
funding rates
meaning you know there was huge leverage
and it was incentivizing
more whales to come in and take the
other side of the trade and go short
so it kind of was something where it
wasn't definite when it was going to
happen but we were definitely prone to
something like this and
it's not very surprising to see yeah and
so
obviously a lot of the leverage
especially the levered longs that's
basically just people saying hey i think
the price is going to go up a lot
there's a lot of
kind of excitement and bullish sentiment
and so people end up adding that
leverage in
how exactly does the leverage get washed
out is that simply just the price begins
to dump and then there's a bunch of
liquidations on the way down and that
then
further accelerates uh the sell-off or
is it something else
yeah exactly so i'm going back to the
the jenga example if you think about you
know when the blocks at the top begin to
fall
it causes the other ones under them and
it becomes this huge cascade right
and so it's the same kind of thing we
saw um what happened with those 9000
bitcoins that got sent into binance
it actually sent the price down to um
the the market's liquidation price the
majority of the markets liquidation
price
which which is basically the point where
where traders that are taking a long
position when they hit that liquidation
price
they're for sell by the exchange to
cover their losses right and so
that that selling pressure um which was
presumed to be caused by those 9 000
bitcoins sent on to binance
was enough to push down the price to
trigger a lot of liquidations
which causes you know the traders to
have to sell to cover their losses
which sends the sends the price even
further down which triggers more
liquidations
right and it becomes this
self-fulfilling thing on the way down
and so that's what that's what really um
drove that initial huge
crash we saw like 15 or 20 percent in an
hour or something crazy like that
it was just basically a cascade of those
liquidations we saw i think
according to the data i'm looking at on
glass node we saw about 1.84
billion dollars of liquidations within
like an hour or two
yeah so i think that was the largest
since and it might actually be larger
than march of last year during the
during the 50 percent drawdown of march
last year
and and that's pretty crazy right when
you think about there's either
potentially
uh more or actually more liquidations uh
happened
uh in a one-hour period over the weekend
then in a day in 2020 when the price
dropped 50 percent
right and that's just the function of
there's way more leverage in the system
right now than there was in march 2020
right
yeah absolutely you know we have a lot
of really bullish sentiment in the
market
um and that that obviously got wiped out
in the last week but you know for for a
while we had everybody thinking we're
going straight to 100 000
and then it became profitable to take
the other side of the trade once once
that
the funding rates really spiked so it
was something that you know it was bound
to happen eventually
but you know i think this is something
where you can see some silver lining
here in the sense that
no one got bailed out right um
in the traditional legacy system when
when everybody has to capitulate
everybody gets wiped out leverage um you
see
you know there's backstops the fed comes
in and bails everybody out
in this in this free and open market
right completely decentralized
everything settles
instantly uh 24 7 right
liquidity goes 24 7. so
when everybody got wiped out there was
no backstop there was nobody to bail
anybody out it's a tr
it's a true free and open market which
is completely contrarian to what we have
today
and you play stupid games and you win
stupid prizes right
when you saw the price dropping it
didn't seem to go
below anywhere like 47 48 000
uh and there was a couple of times where
it kind of dropped you know to 51 came
back to 52 53 then it dropped to 50 came
back to like 51 52
dropped to 47 48 49 came back to 50 but
it just felt like there was like almost
like this floor
uh kind of in that 47 to 50 range is
that
something structurally in the market
does that have something to do with um
kind of leverage or is that just people
stepping in and buying at that price
yeah sure so one of the one of the main
things i personally look at because i'm
i'm a big proponent of the on-chain data
i look at the on-chain volume
so you see there's different support
zones based on
the amount of coins that were moved at
different price levels
so we saw one huge zone of coins that
were moved was was at 53k
and so that kind of served as a little
bit of support for a few days there and
then that broke
and there wasn't much um volume up until
uh behind a 47k which was the next like
major support zone in in terms of
on-chain volume
and so that that served uh twice as a
strong support zone
and then in addition um charles edwards
hash ribbons
um is another thing to look at you saw
briefly it
went flash to buy zone which means that
you know the miner is capitulated and it
became really attractive to buy
and in to off that note with miners you
also saw during this event miners
continue to accumulate
so there's a glass node metric called
minor net position and you saw
throughout the dip
miners actually ramped up their
accumulation
which which was really good to see
because obviously
miners have more skin in the game than
anybody else and they're more bullish on
the asset than anybody else because
they've invested their entire
operational you know expenses
into into bitcoin and bitcoin went wrong
you know everything that they have would
be deemed basically like a paperweight
um so it's good to see them they were
actually accumulating through this whole
dip
and then as well you saw the coins that
were being sold were relatively young
coins
so glass node has a metric called
dormancy and the way you can think of
this is
if a coin has been moved into a wallet
and it's sitting there for one day
it has one day of coin day right and
that's a non-chain metric term and so
let's say
a coin is in a wall for 10 days and then
the coin is sold
um then there's 10 coin days destroyed
and so
dormancy takes a ratio of of the uh the
coin days destroyed through the market
right
and so you saw dormancy actually went
down throughout this sell-off
meaning that the the older coins and aka
you know the long the long-term holders
were not selling during this dip it was
primarily driven by
uh newcomers into the market that
probably got spooked out that hadn't
been through
any of these huge corrections that we
know are you know very well just part of
the way bitcoin operates
so my read of the situation is that even
though there was kind of this wash out
of the leverage
uh a lot of the data that you're looking
at a lot of the data points you're
talking about suggests that the
bold thesis is still very much intact
but the bull market is still intact is
that your read as well
yeah absolutely when you look at um you
know some of the long-term indicators
right
you see that you know the bull market is
still very well
um very far from being overheated
and and none of the major indicators uh
the macro indicators of the cycle are
anywhere near being overheated or
showing any signs of a top
so i you know this is just another
short-term correction that bitcoin has
on the way up
in the last you know cycle on the way up
in 2017
we saw multiple corrections over 30
percent and this is just how the market
works right
you wash out the weak hands the people
that don't have conviction and then the
people with conviction come in and scoop
those coins up
yeah and uh they definitely scoop them
up pretty hard
uh what we've seen over the last 24
hours is i think what makes people so
excited about bitcoin
uh we've seen about a you know 14 15
upward move in price um and uh
it was so violent that uh it just
wrecked a bunch of shorts i think at one
point last night
uh you tweeted saying that there was
over uh 88 million dollars worth of
shorts
uh in just a one or two hour span right
that were all liquidated so talk a
little bit about kind of
uh the shorts are they using leverage
and then liquidations as the price moves
back
up after a drawdown like this yeah
absolutely so
it's the same thing about um what we
talked about when when we
came down right everybody goes long
everybody goes leverage long because the
price goes high
market psychology says okay we're going
higher so i'm going to go leverage long
because we're going higher
and then on the way down we're going
down you know we have some pretty
violent drawdowns everybody gets really
bearish
market you know the market psychology
flips everybody says oh price is going
down so it's going to go way further
down
so i'm going to go leverage and take a
leverage short position
and so the further down we go the more
the more shorts pile in and that was
evident
when you see the funding rates more
people were taking the short side of the
trade
and so it just takes similar to it just
takes a little push
to liquidate people on the way up it
just takes a little push
to liquidate people on the way down so
last night
[Music]
people have been in the bitcoin space
know that whenever we have these
drawdowns you can really tell there's a
bottom because we see the huge violent
just spike up in like an hour or two
right
and that's evident because you see some
buyers step in some huge whale
come in and say okay i'll take those
cheap coins they step in with a huge buy
and then it initiates a chain
of short liquidations on the way back up
when the market gets over
leveraged you know in the short position
and so that's
that's exactly what we saw last night
like you said in two hours we saw 88
over 88 million dollars of short
liquidations which is which is pretty
unprecedented
yeah and what i'm looking at right now
is the bitcoin price as of this
recording is about
eight 53 dollars uh it's up about eight
percent in the last 24 hours
um we're seeing a bitcoin market cap of
a trillion dollars
uh and what to me is fascinating
is you still have over a million uh
active addresses the mining reward is
still
48.8 million dollars uh and 24 hour
period
gbtc is down you know 11 uh on that
discount
and uh from the all-time high we're down
about 17 and a half percent
um and so people look at that and
they're like wait a second
uh this looks pretty bullish even though
we're down that 17 and a half percent
from the all-time high
is this something where we should expect
uh based on a lot of these fundamentals
for price just to rock it right back up
to the all-time high
or how do you see us kind of coming out
of uh one of these bottomings
and uh and a lot of the shorts actually
getting liquidated
yeah it's a great question um so one
thing i'm seeing is i keep
a close eye on stable coin flows so
basically you can track
um the the stable coins that are flowing
onto different exchanges
and this morning we did see a huge batch
of it was over 400 million dollars of
tether
which was moved on to exchanges which is
you know an indication of someone
uh moving stable coins onto an exchange
to buy
and we've seen price go up throughout
the day and so
we haven't seen that many short
liquidations which is kind of an
indication that
the rally throughout the last couple
hours has been driven by spot buying
rather than just
um any kind of short liquidations which
is a good sign
and we're also seeing this you know you
mentioned where we are right now in
price
we're right above that one trillion
dollar threshold and that's really
uh deemed a really strong point of uh
support for bitcoin obviously we dipped
down over the last week
but i think it's over 14 or 15 percent
of bitcoin supply has moved over that
one trillion dollar market cap threshold
which really shows um a strong
validation from the market
of bitcoin as as a macro asset right
for sure as we move forward in the
coming weeks what are some of the data
points that you're going to be looking
at or things
that you want to see from a milestone
basis
sure so i think one thing to look at is
uh the funding rates i know we touched
on this a few times but that can really
be a good
judge of the sentiment of different
market participants
in addition just keeping a close eye one
thing i'm looking at is the entity
net growth so that basically is is
measuring the amount of new users on the
blockchain this isn't taking into
account new users on exchanges but
generally just glass node has different
clustering algorithms that they put
together
addresses and identify them as different
entities so one entity can be
a person right like you or i who has
their own
hardware wallet or it can be a corporate
treasury or it can be
an investment fund right and so
we're seeing this kind of like willy woo
calls it a hockey stick
curve of adoption we're seeing this huge
parabolic increase in
entity growth on chain which we've seen
each cycle we have this huge spike in
that which is which is really good for
the growth of
of the network and the adoption of the
network and we're kind of in that phase
um and and so that's also indicative of
retail
um coming on the network as well um
which which means we're probably
somewhere midway through the cycle we
see
retail coming in usually about midway um
but yeah
i mean just keeping a close eye on some
of these um the broader indicators
it's it's really hard to predict these
these uh moves on the way up because
they have a lot to do with market
psychology
but the the moves on the way down you
can generally time the bottoms pretty
quickly
um i know like one indicator i use is
soaper which
we put in the newsletter last week on
friday which i highly recommend
everybody to check out when it comes out
um and and so sober measures the amount
of profit taking
in aggregate for the network and so
whenever you see sober diplo
one that means that the market is taking
losses in aggregate at
you know if it's at one it means the
market is neutral
above one means that people are in
profit in aggregate but when we go
under that one threshold that means that
the market's in the loss
and so we did see we saw uh super go
below one
back in january um which was like one of
the largest corrections of this cycle so
far
and then for the second time we saw that
happen like two days ago and then we saw
we saw a violent uptick in that which to
me indicated that whoever was going to
capitulate on their holdings
had already done so and that was that
was a huge bottom indicator
so yeah just just keeping an eye on some
of these overheated metrics and
especially in regarding the leverage
because that can
as we touched on be a be a huge uh
catalyst for for some of these huge
drawdowns that we see but
but as far as like the overheated in the
short term um
it's hard to predict because there is
that huge aspect of psychology that
comes into play and you know the fomo
kicks in
a lot of the people that were betting on
the price going down to 40k
you know we see this huge spike up today
and they're like
oh maybe i'm wrong the market's telling
me i'm wrong i better get in before we
go up to 60k
and and the sentiment can change on a
dime um and so i think that's what we'll
probably see over the next couple days
i'll be
keeping a close eye on these short
liquidations for sure
that is uh that's fantastic view of the
world and i tend to think
that uh you frame it best right it's
like a lot of these data points can give
you
um really interesting uh kind of
guardrails or
directional information uh but probably
are not things that
folks want to kind of time the market or
trade off of or anything like that it
more so just helps you
understand what's happening and why it
could be happening
um so i think it's important uh i wish
that somebody could figure out
uh the laser eye metric which would just
be like what percentage of twitter users
has laser
eyes and is there any correlation to
price there as well uh because it seems
like gonna get the glass
absolutely um all right man listen this
is fantastic i really
appreciate you kind of jumping on real
quick and helping explain uh what
happened but
uh for those that are listening uh
basically the summary is very simple
uh folks got overly bullish lots of
leverage in the system uh somebody came
in
dumped about 9 000 bitcoin uh price
starts to
trickle down as that happens those long
levered positions get liquidated which
accelerates a further and further
downward spiral
uh and as that occurs sentiment shifts
people become bearish
they start to then put on leveraged
shorts uh obviously at some point you
kind of exhaust that draw down
and then it violently rips up and it
basically liquidates the shorts
so lesson for each of you at home using
leverage
probably not the best idea especially if
you are
a an inexperienced uh trader
or somebody who simply just wants
bitcoin exposure uh
just bitcoin and chill you'll probably
be much much better off
much less of a stressful situation as
well so we'll
listen thank you so much for taking the
time to do this and uh
people will be hearing much more from
you over time whether it's in the
newsletter future podcast episodes
um and where can we send them to follow
you on twitter
yeah sure so i'm on twitter at wclementi
i am the third in my family and then as
well i'm putting out you know newsletter
for you
on uh every friday which is kind of an
on-chain
update i highly suggest checking those
out because
you know the on-chain metrics are very
um
unique to bitcoin where we're able to
track the the capital flows through the
through the network completely
transparently
um you could basically think of it as
you know if you were in the
in the traditional financial system able
to see every time someone was was
trading cash with each
other that that's the way it is you know
we can see
everything all the movements of coins on
chain and so you can get a really
like you said good outlook of kind of
the macro
um where we are in the broader cycle and
you know the behavior of different kind
of entities so
um that that's what that that's what
that on chain update is on every friday
and that'll be posted on
palms twitter awesome man well listen
thank you so much for doing this and
we'll do it again in the future
absolutely thanks for having me on